follow-up question to what you just said
which is there are wolves that are
watching you like a hawk
is there another reason outside of
national security that they they don't
want you to disclose what you
may disclose or they're worried you may
yeah i mean
what is their worry outside of them
there have been um
you know uh
forbidden truths we can call them if you
will
there have been forbidden truth in the
history of not just our country but many
countries
truths that could upset
a balance a balance that's been around
for a long time
let me give you case in point
[Music]
let's say there were some people that
were doing their job by running a ufo
program in the past
but because certain things happened
presidents were no longer briefed people
in congress were no longer briefed who
should have been and now they're running
an operation that's uh
considered rogue but it's still an
important mission
um
[Music]
turns out you know all of a sudden now
let's say hypothetically the cat's out
of the bag
what's going to happen to those people
when when the government realizes they
were running operations for better or
worse
um without any oversight without any
legal oversight right
what what who who's going to be held
accountable for that the fact that they
did not brief legally like they were
supposed to
certain members of congress and
committees and oversight committees and
and and the chain of command um that's
potentially criminal criminal
action
let's say i've said this before let's
say you have two competing companies you
have uh aerospace company a and
aerospace company b
and aerospace company a for whatever
reason gets a favor and some sort of
really exotic game changing material is
provided to that company to do a
analysis
meanwhile company b who is competing
fairly
doesn't
doesn't get that material turns out
company a now starts getting a lot of
contracts defense contracts and becomes
a multi-billion dollar company while
company b who never had the advantage of
having that material
um
goes into bankruptcy people hundreds of
people lose their jobs and stockholders
lose their their investment
keeping in mind that both companies are
supposed to be treated fairly and have
fair competition
uh when it comes to us government
contracts now what now now what happens
where's the liability
and by the way now these companies are
are you know doing good things for the
united states
um but they got there because they had
an unfair advantage
competitive advantage
potentially again i'm not i'm not this
is hypothetical right
where's the liability there you're
talking to trillions and trillions of
dollars worth of liability
um
you know and and who made those
decisions to do that you know who's
going to be held culpable for that uh
you know security exchange commission
would not be very happy to know that
that to publicly company two publicly
traded companies that were competing for
a contract one had an unfair advantage
the other went bankrupt that's that that
that's a problem that's a real problem
and so you're talking about
big big money interests you're talking
about
things that are going into that gray
world that go beyond just government
interests you're talking about banking
you're talking about
um
you know
some of the biggest names on the planet
that have a lot to lose
or a lot to gain
in hindsight so you know i think we
always have to be careful that that
governments have always had um
interesting ties to to
to certain interests and that's true of
all governments it's not just the u.s
that's everybody
and we need to be mindful of that you
know because you could you could be
you could be um
putting some people in a very
uncomfortable position and i'm aware of
that and that's why i've been very
delicate how i approach this topic i'm
not trying to beat anybody up
i'm not trying to expose anybody and and
say ahaha gotcha see there um i'm trying
to have the conversation in a
collaborative meaningful way where
everybody wins nobody has to get burned
right it's not a zero-sum game i'm not
hypothetically do they view it like that
like there's a potential where everyone
can win or do they view it somewhat with
zero well i can't i can't speak for them
i can't tell you what they think all i
can tell you is what i think and and and
my approach and my approach is to say
look guys
you know we're not trying to expose
anybody this is not true i'm not trying
it's not a witch hunt you know despite
what you may see on social media where
everybody wants their pound of flesh um
that's not going to get us anywhere we
we need to to
we need to be adults about this and we
need to have a conversation that if you
really want the truth to come out you
better be able you better be willing to
compromise
you know this is we're not gonna we're
not gonna sit there and put people to be
eaten by the lions um just to just to
satisfy someone's you know ego or or or
beef that they might have with somebody
else
um you know the truth is more important
than that this is not about
uh see i told you so or or
being vindicated this this is about
having a conversation that's that that
can affect all of humanity and we have
to be willing to
to set aside some of that uh if you will
um
and understandably so you know you've
got lots and lots of decades worth of of
people covering this up i know there's a
lot of animosity and resentment as a
result of that by people saying you know
you've been lying to us for all this
time but
but we've got to be willing to put that
aside if we really want to move forward
in my opinion
you're referring to animosity from the
general public or animosity from some of
these wolves no general public who who
want their pound of flesh because people
have been covering this topic up for too
long knowing that it's real midline to
the american people
speaking about humbling when you mention
the word sober and somber
that
to me the reason why is because not
because we're more special than we think
we are but we're much less so then i was
wondering hmm is perhaps another
motivation for people that will pack
around you not just a financial
motivation not just national security
but also perhaps self-preservation
because absolutely self-preservation
yes that's a huge part of it in fact it
also goes to pride and ego and
self-preservation i mean these are these
are innate components of of the human
psyche and we need to be aware of it and
and a lot of people don't even realize
they're that way um
you know it it it comes from a place of
self-preservation ultimately survival
you know um
control
um
and to some degree even resources
it's
it's almost part of our character um we
you look at any any type of society
whether you have uh a society where you
have a monarchy
a king or a queen making authoritative
decisions
or even to some degree presidents or you
know uh
popes and
you know
again i'm not against any of this i'm
just simply saying that we as a species
we always we always want answers we
always want someone to to have the final
say in narrative because we like we like
our our life to be defined when you look
at the way an average city is city
organizer the reason why we make our
streets and grids north and south east
and west
because subconsciously it helps us know
where we are at any given time why we
have a compass right what time would
look even a watch tells us where we are
in time right we we are a species that
doesn't like we fear the unknown
and when you look at carl sagan's
pale blue dot for the very first time
and you realize that everything in
existence that we know of has occurred
on that tiny little pale blue dot
which is you know three pixels large
in the vastness of vacuum of space
in just one ray of light from the sun
that makes people pretty uncomfortable
you know uh
the fact that you know other than
towards the center of the earth there's
no such thing as up or down
there's really no such thing as left
foot if you go left far enough you come
back right again
uh up is relative
you know up just means i'm moving away
from the center of the earth that's all
there is no real up or down you know we
don't know if we're if we're flying
sideways somewhere in the milky way in
the universe or if we're upside down or
what if there is there's no upside down
there's no
my point is that
when you really look at the universe for
what it is um
we have no idea where we are
none um
we are spinning in an obscure
spiral arm of some obscure galaxy we
happen to call the milky way that's on a
collision course with another galaxy
called andromeda in the next 250 million
years or so uh but in reality we have no
idea where the hell we are or where
we're going or where we've been
and and so we we build these anecdotes
and histories and whatnot because
it helps us make sense from nonsense and
that's that's what we like as human
beings we we don't that's why when you
put people in a solid white room or even
the furniture's white
most people report not only being
disoriented but being uncomfortable
because there's no point of of of
of there's no relativity within the
relativeness within the within that
relative relativeness within the within
the room
um in fact it it that's why death is is
so scary for so many people because it's
the great unknown
um and it's it's something that as a
species we we fear um
a lot
and and you know it's it's part of
nobody wants to know
that they're lost nobody nobody wants to
know that's why safety and security is
so important a lot of a lot of
relationships right people would say i
just want i just want safety and
security that's all i just want to know
that that person is going to be there
for me and i can rely upon them right
they want stability they want they want
an anchor
um and that's not a bad thing that
that's who we are
but we also have to realize there's a
lot of things in this universe
you know
that that are gonna
going to force you to reevaluate and
that's really really uncomfortable once
you really realize that you are truly we
are alone
out here in the universe from a from a
human perspective right i'm not saying
from a living thing or a
you know i'm saying from a human
perspective
um you know
that's scary for a lot of people um
you know best isn't to our knowledge we
are the only humans in in the universe
and of course we have a bunch of animals
we can play with on our little planet
that we call earth and you know kind of
makes kind of makes us feel good but but
it's looking more and more
like every single day that there's
there's there's more out there um it's
just not human and then the question is
okay well what are their intentions what
are the motivations
do they want to work with us or do they
want to subjugate us um or are we going
to be tomorrow's uh dinner menu right um
all these things go through the minds of
people
and and they're they're you know
they're good questions
and what and questions frankly we don't
have an answer for yet and that makes
people really really uncomfortable and
unsettled
and i think we need to be aware of it so
back to your question what
you know
am i am i subject to the same
box bias that you are and everybody else
you damn right i am yeah and we need to
figure out how how to look at this topic
looking potentially a non-human topic
through non-human eyes is what i'm
trying to say
uh we may have to take our glasses our
human glasses off
um that kind of filter how do we do that
in terms well that's my question right
how do we do that
this is exactly why we're having this
conversation what can people be doing
having that conversation exactly that's
exactly what what we could be doing